so wird es echt machen ja ich habe guten
trick wir stecken uns hoch und die story
machen so dass die sportler vom nächsten
level geholt weiß ich meine das ganz
cool
jetzt habe ich aber gar keine
er trieb mich direkt alter alter nein
nein ich am 1
servus es geht sondern bekommt zur
fünften folge von mycroft wanted mit
dabei ist heute der mini kraft 1005 ak
fabio morena es und denn es ist mit
dabei im ts aber jetzt hat mich aber
mach jetzt eine fröhliche runde zu dritt
und wir gehen davon finden sich aber
darauf nicht genau so ne ich mich schon
drauf ich warte schon nur so ein
bisschen sehnsüchtig hat ja ich bin
geräusche nicht gut ich bin mitte wo
bist du eher freimann ich finde wenn man
eine nacht alte da unten
sie ist die einzige die ganze zeit ja
ein schild das jedoch gelassen
ach ja doch was hatte wir werden heute
eine dungeon tour machen ich habe
und ja das ist so und das bisschen mache
schlagfertig ich mache mir ist aber eben
noch kein leid weil da wir haben den
fehler entdeckt da war halt so ist es
dass der mord irgendwie nicht auf dem
server installiert wurde und so deswegen
ging das alles nicht aber jetzt geht das
noch ein bisschen was gucken wir mal was
brauche ich den nummer gunpowder brauche
ich wusste das was kanter estland oder
afrika doch da ich glaube ich fertig als
ich erst mal rüber auf unser feld 24 sie
zum inventar
auch mal ein bisschen donuts gibt
hierfür die wüstenregionen muss ne yo
ist tot
aber die haben gerade unser feld gefegt
hier vor allem ich frag bis sie tot
steht ja nicht nein alter auch komm
schon
komm schon
erst mal übrigens hier jetzt zwischen
stichwort es ist jetzt glaubt
entschieden worden dass wir auf stream
fahren dürfen
es war es wurde über stimmt auf jeden
fall die leute die dafür waren wir haben
abgestimmt und die regeln so sein das
wir dass wir alle
alle zwei tage eine stunde aufs team
fahren dürfen das ist die durch die neue
regel
und das ist ein typischer der stirbt so
und so wird es dann gestaltet werden
ich feiere ich richtig aber irgendwann
ändern menges bond erklären zwar ist es
ein normales buch wenn man rechts geht
macht sieht man hier schon man kann sich
verschiedene sozusagen es sind so hälfte
sage ich mal die man sich auswählen kann
und die einmal die jeden die
verschiedenen fähigkeiten oder helfen
kann und ich standen hier den
mit dem anspringen kann seine level so
gesehen abgibt und die kosten level
nicht warum ich nicht werden kann mit
dem aber habe ich habe was für dich was
wir machen wir machen es mal vor was
hier
achtung weiter als würde das müsste
eigentlich reichen
so jetzt kann ich das dingliche
krippenalter achtung achtung 123 ist das
denn ist ein umhang digger du musst ende
drücken
also hinein fenster gehen und dann
drückst du ende einfach die taste ende
ja dies irgendwo oben rechts auf dahin
ja da kommst ins apg menü der kannst
auch den schild anziehen und so alles
klar
dann habe jetzt bei unseren klopp wir
schauen wie es aussieht
die gute idee es durch sein ob die feier
auf jeden fall
es war bin ich zum überlegen ich glaube
dass greift an und du kannst wenn du ein
problem so das kostet 20 level aber er
hat man durch schnell wieder ich mach
das jetzt einfach mal da seht ihr das
fliegt diese rum und würde ich kann
jetzt wände hochklettern
der junge endermann was genau so ich hab
mir auch hier noch eine geile liste
geschrieben mit denen die uni mal so
machen könnte da steht zum anderen hier
so wie man die nächste dimension kommt
und wie man den ersten boss pont habe
ich mir auch mal angeschaut
vielleicht machen wir dass man der
nächsten folge wenn die bosse wenn die
wirte boxkämpfe mal den slate der der
postillon spawn wollen als agent entity
also die uralte entität ist wollte ding
und der hat ziemlich geld ab soll ich
mir sagen was nicht beschäftige mich ein
bisschen mit dem projekt und jungen dann
lasst jetzt mal auf jeden fall die
dungeon zu starten ja wo wollen wir sind
schon wissen schon sieben minuten
draußen in der nähe
die stadt st du bist du
ich habe ja da ist es okay okay aber wir
können uns dann auch irgendwann diese
entschuldigt aber machen damit dem mund
fliegen kann
dafür brauchen wir aber noch gibt
jetzt kann ich ja okay du bist echt
schnell davon machen wollen
ich habe voll die lecks ich muss glaube
ich kurz mal neu starten und von meiner
zuschauer sehen wir uns gut sagt wieder
josué wieder weg in die alu rad
entwickler alex fahrt auch kurz pause
gemacht wir gehört hat und jetzt ein
bisschen
ich werde aber das geile ist diesen to
it coast bewachsenen mauer der billig
gemacht ich habe mir an
es war so habe eine folge auf genau die
kommunion
da bin ich nicht okay du machen musst du
erst mal sacken oder wie heißt ich bin
zu behindern die mich mal zu schnell für
den ton
ich brenne
die leute seien tomaten sehne ist jedoch
ein alter ja auch noch zu brennen jetzt
auf ich schwöre hätten sich die debatte
geht schon geht schon jetzt aber unten
kommt zu kurz
ich habe ihn als lustigen tricks sind
zwei nicht selbst in brand gesetzt
richtiges chaos sondern machen ja ich
habe guten trick wir wir stecken uns
hoch und die story machen so die
sportler vom nächsten level kaputt weiß
wie ich meine das ganz cool
jetzt habe ich aber gar kein
direkt alter alter nein nein ich meine
sie als 30 junge nein sollte meinen
teams auch schlecht sind
du hast mich gehauen danke alter und die
schilder und rüstung und ärgerlich noch
vier herzen
das ding ist übel starke drei punkte
mehr als in der schweiz
also bin ich relativ schnell die ursache
noch das mit dem text richtig hinbekommt
ich habe jetzt verein gezogen der kam
aber es wird auch angezeigt ich konnte
auswählen da stand aber normales bild
also und in der beschreibung von spex
texture pack default irgendwas falls ihr
eine ahnung hat wie man das beheben kann
könnte es mal die kommentare schreiben
ja und es würden es wird demnächst auch
wieder zwei games um ende gamescom hatte
mir das unter die videos geschrieben
habe welches auf jeden fall machen jetzt
mich vielleicht gleich daneben runde auf
damit er bescheid wurscht und ja ich
muss jetzt auch beenden den extra tour
gewonnen
alles klar ja cool wenn man relativ
kurzes vergnügen und lustig geändert
aber okay dann an meine zuschauer
macht's gut
haut rein und falls die folge gefallen
hat last ein lektor schalten die
kommentare falls irgendwelche kritik ab
wollen sie beim nächsten video wieder